we have this tiny RV Airbnb at the farm here
we have a bit of a problem
we have a Starlink that pushes our Wi Fi down to the RV
since spring we've had some issues with the signal cause of the trees grew
so I'm gonna use this mini handheld chainsaw to cut some trees in
my husband deployed and I could not get the chainsaw started
so this is the perfect tool for anyone who just can start a chainsaw
or just doesn't wanna bother doing that
this made light work of cutting down these small pine trees
it was lightweight easy to use
it comes with two batteries
and I did about 50 trees and I was doing the first battery
I also messed around with changing up the tank before I started
so I knew what I was doing and it was super easy to do
now we have a better signal to the RV and I guess they're happy